[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be talking about the many different
universes in the world of Dragon Ball
super and I will be giving you all of
the useful information that we have on
each of them after the erased universes
were revived by Android 17 swish
following the tournament of power
putting all the information that we have
about the different universes in one
video seems like a good idea especially
since there was a bit of confusion
during the tournament regarding certain
things like why multiple gods of
destruction were still there watching
the fight even though all the universes
except for 7 and 11 were erased by that
point we will be answering that question
and many others in this video but before
we begin I want to give a quick shout
out to merge Goblin for supporting this
video merge Goblin cells anime inspired
clothing including Dragon Ball inspired
merch and when I was contacted by them I
checked out their website and I loved
the vibrant colourful designs but I was
skeptical at first about whether such
detailed designs can really look as good
on a shirt as they do on their website I
asked him to send me a sample so I could
see it for myself and I have to say that
I am really impressed by the quality of
the merchandise I even washed a shirt to
make sure that the design won't wash off
easily and there was no negative effect
on the image after I washed it merch
Goblin features some of the dopest anime
designs that I've ever seen so
definitely check them out link is in the
description as of the making of this
video they are running a 50% off
promotion of the entire store and you
can use the promo code you p10 for an
additional 10% off just be careful with
the sizes merge goblin is based in Asia
so you have to adjust for the size
difference for example I am usually a
large or extra-large in North America
but my size is a triple XL in Asia so
don't mess up those measurements and now
let's get into it at the start of the
tournament of power there are 12
universes all together but only eight
universes took part in the tournament
the four universes with the highest
mortal levels which are universes one
five eight and twelve did not have to
participate in the tournament and
other gods of destruction that we see
watching the tournament were from those
four exempt universes
now that we cleared that up let's talk
about the universes that did participate
in the tournament of power we'll get
back to the other four later and of
course if you happen to be new to this
channel and you want to see more videos
like this one in the future be sure to
leave a like and don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
first up is universe 7 universe 7 is the
one that we know the most about because
that is the universe where the vast
majority of the Dragon Ball story is
taking place out of the 12 universes 7
has the second lowest mortal level at
3.18 at the time of the tournament of
power there are 28 planets inside
universe 7 that have mortals living on
them although other planets like mamak
and Vegeta also supported mortal life
before they were destroyed the universe
7 god of destruction is of course beerus
and his attendant and the universe 7
angel is Wiese
the supreme kai 4 universe 7 is shin
despite the fact that it has the second
lowest mortal level out of all the
universes universe 7 actually has some
of the strongest warriors and of course
we all know that universe 7 emerged as
the victor of the tournament of power
which demonstrates that mortal levels
are not based purely on the strength of
the mortals who live inside those
universes rather mortal levels are
primarily determined by how advanced the
civilizations are within each universe
and how well the gods of destruction and
supreme Kai's are doing their job we
don't know why exactly universe 7 ranks
so low on the mortal level scale but if
I were to speculate it might be related
to the fact that throughout its history
creatures like majin buu and Frieza have
been allowed to cause a lot of chaos and
destruction within universe 7 leading to
large-scale death and suffering feel
free to give me your thoughts down below
on why you think the universe 7 ranks so
low next up is universe 6
the first other universe that we
discover outside of 7 is universe 6
which is the twin universe of 7 remember
that each universe has a twin and
together the numbers of the twin
universes always add up to 13 so 6 plus
7 is 13 and those
two are twin universes one plus 12 is 13
and those two are also twin universes
and so on because universe six is the
twin of seven the two are nearly
identical meaning that at some point
universe six probably had all the same
planets as universe seven however the
history of the two universes is
different so for example the universe
six earth was destroyed before being
wished back by the super Dragon Balls
and the universe six planets addala the
original Saiyan homeworld still exists
even though it was destroyed in universe
7 so while the two universes started out
nearly identical their paths diverged in
various points in history the universe 6
god of destruction is Champa the brother
of beerus his attendant and the universe
6 angel is vados who is the sister of
weeks and in fact it is possible that
all the angels are siblings and the
children of the grand priests the
Supreme Kai of universe 6 is Fuwa and
universe 6 was defeated and erased
during the tournament of power before
they were ultimately wished back into
existence using the super Dragon Balls
the mortal level of universe 6 is just
above universe 7 so it is the 10th
lowest out of the 12 between them
universes 7 and 6 shared the super
Dragon Balls which scattered throughout
both of them after being used then we
have universe 9 universe 9 has the
lowest mortal level out of all the
universes at 1.86
according to individuals who live in
this universe including the trio the
dangers universe 9 is a huge wasteland
and just staying alive is a terrible
struggle the horrible and chaotic living
conditions inside universe 9 may explain
why it has such a low mortal level the
god of destruction for universe 9 is
Sidra and his attendant and the angel of
universe 9 is mojito the Supreme Kai is
ro and unlike in most other universes
supreme cairo seems to be more
aggressive and arrogant than the
universe 9 god of destruction for his
part Sidra seems to be very indecisive
and passive for a god of destruction
which could also explain why universe 9
ranks solo because Sidra isn't doing his
job as the hawk Ison the names of the
fighters from universe 9 are derived
from plants
herbs such as basil lavender oregano and
so on universe 9 was actually the very
first universe to be eliminated during
the tournament of power next up is
universe 4 universe 4 is the twin of
universe 9 and it ranks at number 9 out
of 12 as far as the mortal level goes
the god of destruction for this universe
is Katella and his attendant and the
angel 4 universe 4 is cognac the supreme
kai is kuru Katella looks a lot like a
mouse and he has a sneaky and
manipulative personality and he also has
a strong dislike for universe 7 god of
destruction beerus Katella even plotted
with universe 9 god of destruction Sidra
to assassinate Frieza before he could
join the universe 17 and all of that
with the goal of putting universe 7 at a
disadvantage in the tournament on the
other hand the supreme kai kuru seems to
be far more reserved and dignified than
Katella universe 4 holds the honor of
recruiting the smallest ever fighter
that we've seen in any Dragonball
tournament and that is of course Daum on
the insect warrior universe 4 was
ultimately eliminated from the
tournament of power after Dhawan was
defeated as a result of a joint effort
by members of the universe 7 team
including Goku and Android 17 and so
universe 4 became the fifth universe to
be eliminated in the tournament of power
and now that we've covered the four
lowest ranked universes that took part
in the tournament of power let's get
into the four universes with the highest
mortal level in the tournament first up
is universe 10 ranked eight out of the
12 in terms of mortal level universe 10
is the twin of universe 3 the god of
destruction for universe 10 is Russia
his attendant and angel for universe 10
is cool and the Supreme Kai is go to we
first learned about universe 10 during
the Future Trunks arc as the villain of
that sagas imasu is the former north kai
of universe 10 and in fact samus who was
serving as the supreme kai apprentice
undergo asou at the time of the Future
Trunks arc during this arc goku actually
visited universe 10 with beerus and
weeks at the tournament of power
universe tennis nicknamed the macho
universe due to the fact that it's
fighter's pride themselves on their
muscular
and physical ability the names of the
universe ten fighters are inspired by
chemical elements universe ten was the
second universe to be erased during the
tournament of power after universe 10
fighter a boonie was eliminated by Gohan
then we have universe 3 ranked seven out
of the twelve in terms of the Mortal
level universe 3 is known for its
advanced technology and many of its
fighters in the tournament are either
robots or have highly advanced battle
suits the god of destruction for
universe 3 is mule or mula and his
attendant in the angel 4 universe 3 is
Campari the Supreme Kai is a ax to
further emphasize the technologically
advanced nature of universe 3 where most
of the universe survival saga the
universe 3 god of destruction was
believed to be Moscow a large green
robot who communicates with others
through bleeps however just as universe
3 is about to be erased we learned that
Moscow is actually a robot operated from
the inside by the universe 3 god of
destruction moulay who is a pink
imp-like creature with horns on his head
universe 3 is the sixth or
second-to-last universe to be eliminated
from the tournament of power and this
happens after anna lhasa a warrior that
appears as a result of the merging of
four other universe three warriors is
ultimately defeated by a team effort
from the universe seven fighters the
names of the universe three warriors are
inspired by Italian food so Papa Roni is
derived from pepperoni
pancha comes from pancetta and so on
next up is universe - definitely
everyone's favorite universe universe -
ranked sixth out of 12 in terms of the
Mortal level nicknamed The Gentle
universe universe - inhabitants are
known for valuing love and beauty above
all else the universe - fighters managed
to annoy just about everyone during the
tournament of power by arrogantly
assuming that they were the only ones
who knew what true love is
and by mocking others for not being woke
like them the god of destruction for
universe to his helis the only female
god of destruction her attendant in
universe - angel is sour and the supreme
kai is pal tellus loves beautiful things
and the tests the things that she
considers ugly and both Hellas and pail
have supreme confidence
the superiority of their fighters over
the fighters from other universes
universe 2 is home to two races that can
also be found in universe 7 at least at
one point in time and this includes the
odd rats and the toughest universe 2 is
also home to everyone's favorite dragon
ball super character of all time rib
Rhian and yes in case you couldn't tell
that is sarcasm the names of the
universe two warriors are based on
different types of meat so for example
zur Lowen comes from sirloin steak and
Brienne the Chateau comes from
Chateaubriand steak universe 2 was the
third universe to be eliminated from the
tournament of power after its fighters
were taken out by Android 17 and 18
along with Goku and then we have
universe 11 the twin of universe to
universe 11 ranks 5th out of 12 in terms
of mortal level and is the highest
ranked universe that still had to
participate in the tournament of power
the god of destruction for universe 11
is Bell mod his attendant in universe 11
angel is margarita and the supreme kai
is Kai and that's Kai with a ke h AI
universe 11 is home to the pride
troopers an elite team of heroes who
protect their universe under the
supervision of Bell mod the leader of
the pride troopers topo is also the
candidate for the next god of
destruction for universe 11 the names of
the primers are inspired by kitchen
utensils and utilities nicknamed the
Justice universe the universe 11
fighters in the tournament are all
members of the pride troopers and their
self-described mission is to destroy
evil and defend justice but of course
later on in the tournament we learned
that topo and G R and at times seemed to
confuse justice with strength which is
not always the same thing
Universal Emin is known for being home
to jiren a mortal who is stronger than
the gods of destruction and thanks to
jiren universe 11 remained in the
tournament of power until the very end
but when jiren was finally defeated by
Goku Android 17 and freeze universe 11
was erased only to be brought back again
along with the other universes thanks to
Android 17 swish and now let's talk
about the four highest ranked universes
which were not required to participate
in the tournament
of power because they have an average
mortal level above seven we don't know
as much about these universes as we do
about the other eight because we've only
ever met their gods of destruction
supreme Kai's and angels but not any of
their fighters and so on universe eight
ranks fourth on the Mortal level scale
and is nicknamed the diligent universe
the god of destruction is luckier a
humanoid Fox with three tails and yellow
fur the universe eight Angeles corn and
the Supreme Kai is ill the Supreme Kai
and god of destruction of universe aid
were both relieved when they realized
that their universe would be exempt from
the tournament as of course were the
deities for the other three exempt
universes universe five ranks third on
the Mortal level scale and it is the
twin universe of eight the god of
destruction is Iraq the angel is
cockatiel and the supreme kai is oma
universe five is nicknamed the balanced
universe and both the god of destruction
and supreme kai of universe five put
great value on discipline and knowledge
oma is also the only female supreme kai
in the 12 universes universe 12 ranks
second on the mortal level scale and is
known as the ultimate universe it's god
of destruction is gene a green humanoid
who has scales and Merman type ears his
attendant and the angel of universe 12
is Martino and the Supreme Kai is Boog
or Abu both Kean and Boog are very proud
of their universes accomplishments and
they strive to advance their universe
even higher than it already is
the first mortal to ever create a time
machine came from one of the advanced
civilizations of universe 12 and finally
universe 1 the universe with the highest
mortal level and also the twin of
universe 12 nicknamed the supreme
universe is god of destruction is he
when it's angel assalamo and it's
supreme kai is ánot we don't know very
much about universe 1 in terms of
specifics but the fact that this
universe has the highest mortal level
out of all the universes tells us that
it must have very advanced civilizations
and it also tells us that the god of
destruction and supreme kai of universe
one must be extremely effective at doing
their jobs and that is it finally all
universe is explained in one video
however it is important to remember that
there were once 18 universes in the
world of Dragon Ball super but six of
them were erased at some point in the
past because Zeno was in a bad mood at
the end of the tournament Android 17
praises his wish like this please
restore all of the universes that were
erased because Android 17 does not say
restore all the universes that were
erased during the tournament but simply
all the universes that were erased
period it is possible that those other
six universes which were erased earlier
might have been wished back by the super
Dragon Balls if that is the case then
there are now once again 18 universes
instead of 12 but at this time we don't
know anything about those other six
universes so we can talk about them yet
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more be sure to leave a like to
let me know if you are new to the
channel don't forget to subscribe and
hit that notification bell for more
Dragon Ball content and don't forget to
check out merch Goblin and take
advantage of their deals the link is in
the description be sure to let me know
down in the comments which universe is
your favorite and why as always thank
you all so much for watching and until
next time see us space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]